für meine frau mit der prosecco und ich
nehme an nati ni.com sofort vielleicht
für mich doch lieber ein abhol spritzt
er wissen sie schon was sie essen
möchten ja für meine frau bitte ein
kalbsrieth otter und ich nehme den
gebratenen zander salzkartoffeln oder
kroketten dazu
oder vielleicht doch lieber
salzkartoffeln zu trinken bitte
vielleicht für die dame anwendung für
mich ab ihr ein kleines bier ein kleines
kaltes bier aber vielleicht nicht zu
kalt vielleicht lieber so raumtemperatur
ich nehme vielleicht doch lieber nein
der onboard oh nein mario hatte denn wir
nehmen wir doch ein weißwein und zum
tresor vielleicht doch eher ein klavier
handy doch lieber gern an martini und
pommes zum zander wir kürzen das ganze
jetzt ab sie und ihre werte gattin
bekommen von mir ein paar wiener wirst
du dazu gibt sauerkraut und eine
apfelschorle vielen dank für die
bestellung